we did our launch of our supplement
brand in the first month we did 1.7
million it was like mid and I thought
about it one day and I was like there's
literally nothing that could have
happened that I would have been happy
about my expectations are so high that
like everything is a disappointment God
it's like I'm so impatient and as we
were walking and she was like no you
don't she's like you're patient is like
what have your actions have been
impatient you feel uncomfortable and you
don't like the speed that things are
growing because you never like the speed
that things are growing she's like but
you never change the course and so that
means that you are patient you're just
uncomfortable which is what makes you
patient people think that patience is
being at peace at all times like no you
can feel terrible but the fact that you
choose to continue down the path is what
makes you a patient person it's much
more about the activity and the actions
that you choose to take rather than how
you feel about the actions while you're
doing them and she was like your patient
is like you just hate it